it will haunt you every night whatever
they are no one should have to encounter
that kind of evil except you girls I
think you can handle it Oh
oh good thanks somebody is trying to
unleash the dead on New York City and we
may be the only ones that can save it
why am i operating the untested nuclear
laser you have the longest arms fire oh
these women are just bad I'm sure she
just misspoke sad bored lonely sad women
oh no I'm here about the receptionist
job hi you're hired
not you're all sweaty there are people
out there that need our help the card
letter we need to form a group then
build something to fight these damned
ghosts
that's exactly what we already do here
something big is gonna happen
I think the work we're looking for is
Apocalypse
we don't want mass hysteria Kevin can
you answer the phone cause it's in the
fish tank the one on the desk oh what's
the place called conductors have the
meta physical examination go to
Ghostbusters no I'm tired
no no just gonna go ahead and take off
how about that want to take off
don't upset the ghosts really Jose
bosses if there's a paranormal problem
we are the ones to answer the call hello
this must be